some very inventive kills aren't they
did he have a favorite one
oh my favorite kill is probably it's
probably when he cut somebody's stomach
open rips out his guts inflates it like
a balloon turns it into a dog and then
approaches the kids he's got his blood
you know his stomachs all the Bloods
coming out and he approaches the kid
with the dog and goes woof woof so
that's that's not even the kill that's
the bit on the way to the and then as
the kid runs off he trips on his
entrails and then he gets stitches gets
a balloon pump and you have to see the
film if you want to find out how the
balloon pump is utilized as a murder
weapon
that's quite something you need to watch
it out definitely yes
you mentioned kind of balloons they're
in twist even different shades it made
me think of your street experience as an
entertainer did that help at all with
that yeah well I used to do before I
started doing stand-up I used to make
children's and the teenage doom
yeah juggling and all that sort of stuff
and so we do that's all in there you
know juggling and balancing things on my
chin but I had to make it look like I
was bad at it but all of the stuff like
there's a lot of before he kills people
he kind of does a lot of like spins the
knife you know he'll flicks the knife
around and there's a bit where I kill a
girl and an umbrella and he can of the
umbrellas on the floor and he flicks it
up and it spins in the air and he does
all that and that was that's that's all
me that's no special effects I saw me
I'm like Jackie Chan yeah it's a very
physical role as you say and you're a
big biker aren't you an off-road bike
does that help you with preparation for
doing it as well it was actually a whole
bit that was cut out that there's a
chair spit which involves me on a tiny
tricycle
there was a whole thing where we were on
a mountain bike and we stubborn the seat
and then I had a big fly through the air
and smashed through a barrier and it
kind of in the end like to kind of make
it work
it's a haul but that was lost so which
is fine it works brilliantly and doesn't
really need that many but yeah it was
great we just sort of in fact at one
point Connor the direct that didn't have
to see it can we just remember that the
CFT first because I was going you know
smashing I shouldn't just hit me hit me
one thing you know because I know it's
just no no I'll just fall on there the
stunt people are going get we have to
put mats down and I it's fine it's like
yeah just there was a there was one bit
actually where I still just get smashed
in the face with a fridge door and and
with that the way the shot was doing it
smashed in the fierce and then I had to
fall backwards but because you could see
the floor before the camera moved the
the stunt guys had to they have to shove
the mat in at the last minute so when I
walk across the floor there's no map
there and you see the floor and then I
just have to trust that they get their
mat so he's smashed nevere snow just go
like that
I just fallen back what's going to
please please let them have fun in him
so yeah they got hardcore it's now I can
see it's got to be in the DVD extras
those things as well that weren't
actually in the film surely yeah yeah
well there's a bit sort of at the end in
the credits where I was flicking the ice
flicking the umbrella around and he got
caught on the boom so I go flick like
that and I'm hooked put my hand over to
catch it and it just steers who's just
oh okay I believe he had a bit of an
incident where you went into a pub as
world filmmaker yeah yeah that's right I
was there we were filming the grit all
the outdoor graveyard stuff and I was
desperate for the toilet so I went into
a pub and
I walked in there and a hope of just
like a small country pub in Ireland and
this clown walks through the face or
slashed up and they all will
and I just didn't and I got so used to
because my whole fit my eye and
everything was all glued down like from
first thing in the morning to it got
quite weird it got to the point I
couldn't judge distance anymore and so I
went in the toilet and there stood at
the urinal and the guy next to me all
right didn't bat an eyelid and then went
back out then I was chatting of some of
the guys in the pub and they still hold
woman came up and she just went and no
are you an actor and she went because I
know you're fierce from somewhere they
are really you know half my fierceness
are horrible but didn't you when you
went into a chemist because you had your
hands very bloody didn't you tell me
what happened oh yeah that's right yeah
I him I did the blood actually stand my
hands so I went into a chemist and
without thinking I said I said if you've
got anything that can get this blood off
the hands they were like no no it's it's
not it's not my blood it's a it's it's
the woman's going it's like see how it's
not it's not real blood it's just yeah
I've what you've been doing I've been
killing teenagers I know you are a big
horrifying yourself on you what the kind
of inspirations for you when you were
doing this film when I was doing this
well well well basically I wanted to
like when I was a kid I loved the maniac
cop series you know and so there was a
so there's a nod to that but what I
wanted to do was basically it was all of
those classic
you know / you know there was real sort
of slush our bodies
I wanted stitches to be like that but I
wanted them to where as all those
classic slush our bodies are American I
wanted them to be like that but very
British so he's sort of like the way I
describe it is is a Freddy Krueger went
on holiday and he got his tough mate in
and went look can you just he's sort of
like a supply killer he's the sort of
look that you just go look if you slip
this bloke a few quid he'll do a bit
killing for you that's next week you now
Russ I'm just about to start well the
film comes out on general release in
October and I'm just about to start a
big life to us or back to my dear job
for a bit and then there hopefully I'll
there I'll get to kill some teenagers
soon yeah brilliant we look forward to
stitches coming out and the tour as well
great to speak to your earth
you